All right.
I asked you to come in with definite
lists of where Paul was when according to
two different sources.
The purpose of the lecture today is to
get you to see what you may think of as a
historical text as actually not
a very reliable historical text.
This is not to say
anything about your faith,
it's not to say anything about how you
might use this text religiously are
theologically and other words.
It is not my intention to attack the
reliability of the Bible for theological
reading or for faith or your
personal beliefs about the Bible.
But what we will do is demonstrate a
difference today between reading this text
theologically a scripture and reading
it as historical source simply as a text
or a series of texts actually
cause as you know by now,
the New Testament is
a collection of texts.
If all you had were these documents
about the first several decades at the
beginning of Christianity,
and as a matter of fact,
all you have as documents
for the first sec,
a few decades of Christianity
are the new testament texts.
There are documents not
in the new testament,
but they tend not to tell us anything
we want to know about, for example,
the very beginnings of of Christianity
as a movement. So what you've gotten,
the new testament comprise at least the,
uh,
some of the earliest material we have.
If you want to know about the
life of Jesus, for example,
the four Canonical Gospels with
perhaps the gospel of Thomas,
which we'll be reading later,
give you basically only
the only information about
Jesus of Nazareth available
to historians.
The same thing for Paul there our second
century sources that talk about Paul or
they claim to be letters by Paul,
but most of us scholars don't
believe they have any historical,
reliable information.
So what we've got about Paul is
what you have in the New Testament.
I'm going to try to get you
to use two of those sources,
Galatians and the acts of the apostles.
And then we're going to talk about what
can we know about Paul from these two
texts. So now pick your list
out that you made for acts.
When is the first time we see
the Apostle Paul in acts chapter,
in verse.
I'm a former fundamentalist,
which means I want chapter
and verse on everything.
Perfect
chapter and verse. When was the
first time we see Paul? Yes sir.
Nine one.
And where is he
on the road to Damascus?
We starts off in Jerusalem.
Yeah.
Now is that actually the first time we
see Paul in the book of Acts Perfect
in seven 58 so we actually
see him before then.
And what's where is he there?
That's right. He was witnesses.
The stoning of Stephen,
who by tradition is the
first Christian martyr,
first person to die for Christianity
and acts. And he's in what city?
Where's he? Come on
folks quicker. Quicker.
Where's the and he's in Jerusalem.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Now let's just read that first part there.
They dragged him out of the city.
That is, Steven began to stone him.
The witnesses laid their coats at
the feet of a young man named Saul,
who the writer of acts will
later tell us is also named Paul.
So stall is acts depixol
as his Jewish name.
And Paul is sort of his
great Greek and Roman name.
While they were stoning Stephen,
he prayed and so forth.
Look at eight one and Saul approved of
their killing him that day as severe
persecution began against
the church in Jerusalem.
All except the apostles were scattered
throughout the countryside of Judea and
Sumeria. Devout men buried Stephen
and made loud limitation over him.
But Saul was ravaging the church
by entering house after house,
dragging off both men and women. He
committed them to prison. So Saul,
as he's known here,
is fairly active in Jerusalem as a
persecutor of the followers of Jesus.
He causes several. You've arrested, they
know who he is, they would recognize him.
He's got a reputation.
So that's where the first time we see
Paul is seven 58 and then we the con,
the acts as we'll see,
does a lot of other things.
And then comes back to Paul.
Now at nine one so after nine one
when's the next time we see Paul?
And x
goes,
he's on the road to Damascus. Did y'all
do this homework? Yes sir. In the back.
Rolling 1225
and what?
Where is that?
Okay. Barnabas and Paul
go back to Jerusalem.
Let's back up a bit.
So I think we're missing some stuff.
I want every detail of time,
every detail of place.
Look at nine 26
when he had come to Jerusalem,
he attempted to join the disciples.
They were all afraid of him for they
did not believe he was a disciple,
but Barnabas took him, brought him
to the disciples, the apostles,
and describe for them how on the road he
had seen the Lord who had spoken to him,
how in Damascus he had
spoken Bogan name of Jesus.
So he went in and out among in Jerusalem
speaking boldly in the name of the
Lord. He spoken, argued with the
Hellenistic, that is Greek speaking Jews,
but they were attempting to kill him.
When the believers learned of it,
they brought him down to Cesarea
and sent him off to tarsus.
So notice in chapter nine you've got
several chronological and spatial details
about Paul. That's what I wanted you
to notice. Not just read it quickly.
Don't read this stuff like
college students read it
as really critical readers,
not just to get the reading done,
but notice the details. Now I'm,
I'm that stressing this now because over
and over again in this semester, we'll,
we'll try to push you to read it
much more carefully noticing details.
That's the only way to
practice close reading. Okay,
so we've got him in Jerusalem,
we had a Damascus,
but before 1225 we have lots of other
material with him being in Jerusalem
and introduced to the church there.
And when is this chronologically?
You don't have to know the year,
but how much time are we talking about
between this Damascus period and this
time?
Barnabas introduces them to the rest of
the church and gets them accepted by the
church. Yes. Just as in
after some time had passed,
there's one place where it says he's
three days in Damascus after he sees Jesus
before he's baptize. So we have
three days, then he's bad ties.
And then he disputes with
other people in Damascus.
But basically just after some time.
So it can't it,
we're probably not talking
several years here. Right.
You get the impression when you're reading
this that you know, it may be months,
it may be weeks.
Okay, so then, so this
is time in Jerusalem. Um,
what happens after Barnabas
introduced them Jerusalem.
Look at nine 30 when the
believers learned a bit,
they brought him down to Cesarea and
sent him off to tarsus. So again,
before we get him in Jerusalem
here he's in Cesarea,
which is a city on the coastline
of Palestine and he's in Tarsus.
Why does he go to Tarsus? Do
you think that's his home?
Exactly. According to
acts, Paul is from tarsus.
Now when we get further,
I'll point out when we know,
when we have information about Paul
that we get from his letters and when we
have information about part of the,
we only get from acts and with
the question I'll ask you is,
are they both reliable?
Are they both equally reliable?
If you have one piece of information from
Paul's letters and a different kind of
a piece of information from ax is one
of them more likely to be historical.
Those are the kinds of questions
we'll ask. Yes sir. Tarsus is, um,
in the very eastern part of what
is now Turkey. Okay. So it's,
it's not far from the border of
eastern Turkey and western Syria.
It's in modern Turkey at the time.
At that time it was in
the area called Cilicia.
And that'll be important because
when we get to Galatians,
Paul talks about going to solicit
at one point and I'm going to say,
why did he go to solicit and where is
that? And some smart person's gonna say,
well, isn't Parsis the main capital
city of Cilicia and Iranian part?
And I'll say, that's brilliant. You
made a very important connection there.
Okay,
so he goes to tarsus.
Now you don't hear him much about,
uh,
Paul because then you have
other kinds of stuff. And then
look at 11,
19.
Now those were scattered because of the
persecution that took place over Stephen.
Notice how it will get this and then we'd
get to the acts of the apostles or the
electric on that. There's a been
a jump here in the period of time.
The stoning of Stephen was way back
there at the end of Chapter Seven,
the beginning chapter eight.
Then you had a lot of other material
now that the authors kind of taking you
back to that stoning of Stephen episode.
So this is like one of those things
that you know, it's a cutaway. It's a,
it's a time lapse sort of uh,
in, in the, the filming here,
they traveled as far as Phoenicia,
Cyprus and Antioch and they spoke
the word to no one except Jews,
but among them were some men from
Cypress and Cyrene who aren't coming to
Antioch.
Spoke to the Helen is also proclaiming
the Lord Jesus and the hand of the Lord
was with them in a great number of
became believers and turned to the Lord.
News of this came to the ears
of the church in Jerusalem.
They sent Barnabas to Antioch.
When he came and saw the
grace of God, he rejoiced.
He had exhorted them all to
remain faithful to the law
with step, have devotion.
Free was a good man,
full of the host,
bit of faith and a great many
people were brought to the Lord.
Then Barnabas went to
Tarsus to look for Saul.
So again,
before we get this,
we have Saul going to Antioch
again, Barnabas being the
important figure who does that.
Uh, when he came, he saw the
grades, we've got blah, blah, blah.
Then Barnabas went to Tarsus
to look for Saul and uh,
when he found him, he brought
him to Antioch. So it was
that for an entire year.
They met with the church and taught a
great many people and it was an Antioch
that the disciples were
first called Christians. Um,
at that time profits came down from
Jerusalem. So we have one year here
in Antioch.
Before the next incident happens,
one of them named Agablith stood up and
predicted by the spirit that there would
be a severe famine over our little world.
This took place during
the reign of Claudius.
The disciples determined that
according to their ability,
each would send relief to
the brothers living in Judea.
This they did sending it to the
elders by Barnabas. And Saul.
So in 1130 we have Paul
going from Antioch,
with Barnabas
to Jerusalem,
taking with them funds to alleviate
famine for famine relief in Judea from the
disciples in Antioch. Okay.
When's the now after that,
do we have another time we see Paul,
that's when you get the 1225 Barnabas,
after completing the mission,
Barnabas and Saul returned to
Jerusalem and brought with them John,
whose other name was mark.
Actually, I think that may need to be
returned from Jerusalem. There's a,
there's a um,
manuscript debate over whether they
returned to Jerusalem or from Jerusalem,
but in any case there in Jerusalem and
then 13 one that we find them back in
Barnabas, Barnabas, and Saul there.
So chapter 13 has Barnabas and Saul
and Antioch.
Again,
while they were worshiping the Lord
and fasting, the Holy Spirit said,
set apart from me Barnabas and Saul
for the work to which I've called them.
Then after fasting and praying, they laid
their hands on them and sent them off.
They went by the Holy Spirit.
They went to Solutia. Okay.
Then we have what's called the
first missionary journey. All right,
so this is the first week
you're near Barnabas and Paul.
They travel through that part of central
and southern Turkey that we call Asia
minor if for the ancient
world called Turkey. Now,
so what happens next after
13 one where does Paul go?
Yes sir.
Okay, so they, they have a confrontation
with the magician called bar Jesus.
Where else? Yes. Cyprus.
Yep. So Cypress Psalmist, they're
traveling around. Where else?
Where do they end up?
Sorry,
I conium it's another
place they go to next.
Lystra Darby.
Next Durga.
Pega.
Next
video video. Where do they end
up after that first journey?
At the end of the journey.
Back in Antioch.
Okay,
so we're going to include all those places
you just said in the first missionary
journey and then they end up and Antioch.
Where's the next place they go?
Jerusalem.
What do they do this time in Jerusalem?
Sorry.
They have a debate. The whole, the leaders
of the church get together. They debate.
What's the topic of the debate
whether gentiles have to be circumcised
to be members of the community and who
makes the decision? Pardon?
Who makes the decision?
Somebody, right? Somebody say
it out loud a lot. Enough,
sorry James. They all make the
decision together. In fact,
they say it seemed good to the Holy
Spirit and to us that's an interesting way
of putting it because in the book of acts,
the Holy Spirit is actually the
main actor of the whole book.
The Holy Spirit does all this kind of
stuff in the book of acts and so that's
why the acts of the apostles
is almost a MS title.
It judged to be called the acts of the
Holy Spirit a much more accurately for
the narrative,
but the holy spirit and with all the
beliefs and James who's considered the
leader of the church in Jerusalem
actually announces that decision,
but it's a is this isn't.
They all came to by consensus.
Everybody agrees that no gentiles don't
have to be circumcised and they make
some rules. They say that they
shouldn't eat meat sacrificed to idols.
They cert shouldn't eat blood.
They shouldn't commit
fornication or sexual immorality.
So they make some rules that they
expect gentile followers to follow.
They get those rules from the Jewish
tradition that these were the rules that
were given to Noah after the flood.
That so therefore all people in the world,
because all people of
course that now exist,
came from the people who lived
through the flood, right?
So all people in the world, we're
given these rules, even gentiles.
And so even pious gentiles
should keep these rules,
although they do not have
to be circumcised. So
that's the way that happens.
Where, where does Paul go
after that? We're going to move
quickly. Now. Part. Pardon?
Antioch. Back to Antioch. And then
he and Barnabas have a falling out.
I had to have a disagreement.
What's the disagreement between
Paul and Barnabas about enacts,
whether to take John Mark with them
on the next journey? They go, uh,
Paul wants to, it's wants to
take mark. Paul doesn't, is
that the way it goes? Yeah.
And then they split up. It's a very
amicable split and acts, right?
It's a personnel decision. They don't
have any debates about doctrine.
They don't have any disagreements
about what the Gospel means.
about, uh, eating our circumcision.
Barnabas and Saul and Paul split up
simply over a personnel decision about
whether to take John Mark on
the next missionary journey.
So that's notice where we got,
how often is Paul in
Jerusalem before that?
Before this main Jerusalem Council,
how many times?
One, two, three, four,
five.
He's in Jerusalem five times before the,
the General Council that we, that we sort
of ended up a little narrative there.
Now look at Galatians
and we don't have to go all
the way through Galatians,
but we're going to read the part of
Galatians much more carefully and closely.
It's only basically the first
two chapters that we need.
And again,
we're going to put the details up on
the board cause I want you to pay much
closer attention to this then
apparently some of you paid anyway,
one 11 I want you to know,
brothers, his brothers and said,
may say ancestors in
your English translation,
but it doesn't in the Greek that the
gospel that was proclaimed by me is not of
human origin, for I did not receive it
from a human source, nor was I taught it,
but I received it through a
revelation of Jesus Christ.
So first Paul starts out
on the letter saying,
I didn't get my gospel
from any human person.
I got it straight from Jesus.
Now remember,
Paul didn't know Jesus
during Jesus' own lifetime.
So he's referring to a
revelation experience that
he had when he saw Jesus and
some kind of visionary
experience or another place.
He says he was lifted up
into the third heaven.
So we'll talk at some point about what
kind of experience was this that Paul had,
but that's where he got his gospel.
You have heard no doubt of
my earlier life in Judaism.
I was violently persecuting the Church
of God and was trying to destroy it.
I advanced in Judaism beyond many among
my people are the same age for I was
more zealous for the
traditions of my ancestors.
But when God who had set me apart before
I was born, called me through his grace,
was pleased to reveal something so that
I might proclaim among the gentiles.
I did not confer with any human being.
Now,
where is Paul at this point?
According to his own statement.
Wow.
We don't know. Right. But
we know one place he's not.
And where is that? Because
we've got, then he said,
I did not,
nor did I go up to Jerusalem to those
who are already apostles before me.
But I went away at once into Arabia
and afterwards I returned to Damascus.
That's how you know where he was.
I returned to Damascus.
So where is the first place
we see Paul chronologically.
Geographically according to his letter,
his Damascus.
Okay.
Okay, let's keep them. Then he says, um,
I went to Arabia Arabia at this date
at time refers to the part on the other
side of the Jordan River from Judea.
So it's what we would call modern Jordan,
mainly. Maybe eastern Syria, western
Jordan. But that's what it was.
Arabian desert. That's,
so he's talking about,
he went away to that area that we
would not call eastern or Jordan.
I remember Damascus is one
of the large cities in Syria,
so that's where he goes.
Um,
afterwards I returned to Damascus.
Yeah.
After three years we'd get
a nice little chronological
note. I did go to Jerusalem
to visit CFUs. Who has CFUs?
Peter. Yeah, exactly. So Peter cfs is
the Aramaic word for rock or stone.
And Peter is the Greek word
for rock or stone. So again,
we have two different names.
So he goes to Jerusalem
to meet Peter,
but he says,
and I stayed with him for 15 days.
So this first trip and
Jerusalem takes 15 days.
Yeah,
no,
just what he says then.
But I did not see any
other apostle except James,
the Lord's brother.
Is that Jesus. His brother.
Yes. Somebody said,
according to Roman Catholic tradition,
Jesus didn't have any brothers. Uh,
but according to the New Testament,
he did have brothers and maybe
sister's according to some manuscripts.
So James is called the brother
of Jesus in the book of acts.
Don't confuse this with James, son of
Zebedee, who was one of the 12 apostles,
has a different James. There
are several James's, uh,
cause it was a very common name in
the ancient world. And you know,
of course James is just the
Anglos Ization of Jacob.
So it's actually Jacob in the
Greek and that's the word it is.
It becomes James in English.
So James,
the Lord's brother in what I'm
writing to you before, God,
I do not lie.
What,
why does Paul have his panties in a wad
confirming that he only was there 15
days and he only saw Peter and James.
I swear it, I swear it. I swear it.
Then I went into the regions
of Syria and solicit.
Okay.
Why do you think he went to solicit IA?
That's where tarsus is. Maybe that's a
clue that he actually was from tarsus.
Although Paul doesn't never
tell us he's from Tarsus,
so we don't know that's
his hometown from him,
but that's what acts says is his hometown.
So what maybe he went to Tarsus,
we don't know.
He just says he went to seriousness.
I was still unknown by site to the
Churches of Judea that are in Christ.
They only heard it said the one who
formally was persecuting us is now
proclaiming the faith and the ones tried
to destroy and they glorify God. I did.
I was not known by sight.
They heard my reputation.
They heard that I persecuted
followers of Jesus, but nobody,
no follower of Jesus in Judea knew what
I looked like except Peter and James
and he's two swears it.
He's very adamant.
Then after 14 years,
so we have a 14 year period of time.
I went up again with Barnabas
taking Titus along with me.
I went up in response to a revelation.
Why does he say he went up
in response to a revelation?
You might have an idea.
Yes. No. As we'll see
throughout this letter.
Paul is a month to make it very clear
that he is not playing second fiddle to
anybody in Jerusalem. He didn't get
his gospel from those disciples.
He didn't get it from Peter and James.
He got it straight from Jesus.
He didn't check his gospel out with them
at this point. He got it from Jesus.
Paul is trying to establish
his independence from the
church in Jerusalem and
he's eventually gonna try to establish
that I'm just as much an apostle as they
are. I went up the
responsibility. In other words,
he went up in response to a revelation
that God appeared. God's told, uh,
Pete Paul according him go to Jerusalem.
He didn't go because the
Jerusalem authorities said,
we need to check you out and see if
you're okay. Come to Jerusalem. They did.
This was not a command performance.
He's insisting that I laid before them
though only in private meeting with the
acknowledged leaders,
the gospel that I proclaim among the
gentiles in order to make sure that I was
not running or had not run in vain.
But even Titus who was with me was
not compelled to be circumcised,
though he was a Greek,
but because of false believers,
secretly his causes pro false brothers
secretly brought in who slipped into spy
out the freedom that we have in Christ
Jesus so that they might enslave us.
We did not submit to
them even for a moment,
so that the truth of the Gospel
might always remain with you.
And and from those who are supposed
to be acknowledged leaders what they
actually were make no difference to me.
God shows no partiality. Notice again,
Paul is really kind of angry and anxious
about not wanting to cede any authority
to these Jerusalem leaders
except as they are local leaders.
Those leaders contributed nothing
too new to me. On the contrary,
when they saw that I had been entrusted
with the Gospel for the uncircumcised,
just as Peter had been entrusted
with the Gospel for the circumcised,
for he who worked through Peter,
making him in a positive of
the circumcised also work
through me and sending me
to the gentiles.
And when James and CFUS and John,
this is James the Lord's brother,
CIF as Peter and the disciple
John who acknowledged pillars,
recognize the grace
they've been given to me.
They gave to Barnabas and me
the right hand of fellowship,
agreeing that we should go to the
gentiles and they to the circumcised.
They ask only one thing
that we remember the poor,
which was actually what I was eager to do.
Now,
there's a big question here is
what Paul is describing here.
Basically this Jerusalem conference,
is it his version?
It's quite different.
At the white Paul Paul x complexities,
it's mainly him and sort of the
leaders of the Jerusalem church.
You'd get together. It's not. It
wasn't brought about by some crisis.
Paul went because God told him to do so.
They could just all make sure
that they have an agreement.
They make an agreement. Gentiles
don't have to be circumcised. Cut.
Nobody pressured except these
false brothers Titus to be
circumcised the pillars.
Peter, James and John did not
insist that gentiles be circumcised.
They agreed with Peter's
with Paul's Gospel. The next
thing that happens though.
So look at what Paul says.
He starts in Damascus.
Here's an Arabia who's Damascus,
three year period of time he's
in Jerusalem, but only 15 days.
He only sees Peter and James.
Then he goes back to,
goes to Syria and solicit and
then after 14 years later,
so it's some scholars say,
well is this 14 years including the
three years that is as this 14 years from
his revelation or we have 17 years.
So when you,
when you try to figure out the
chronology for Paul's ministry in life,
you have to make that decision.
I think that what's more likely is this
14 years is sincere to be 14 years after
this,
three years.
So you've got 17 years that would put
this Jerusalem meeting in about 17 years
after Paul's own conversion.
If he was converted,
he seems to be converted very early,
are called to be an apostle very early.
If Jesus died around the year 30
perhaps Paul, let's say just pay.
Paula got his revelation in 34
so you'll be talking, you know,
17 years after say 34 or 35 is when you
have this Jerusalem conference and then
you have the the next thing.
Now what happens next though?
Now what that basically is saying,
let's just stop here and say, okay,
how do you make this fit,
this,
how do you make this fit?
This on over here you have Paul starting
off in Jerusalem and he's persecuting
the disciples.
How can he then say over here that
they had never seen him face his face?
Yeah.
Were all of them dead by this time?
He swears they didn't know his face,
which seems to me to say that Paul is
claiming he wasn't in Jerusalem when he
was persecuting the church.
He was persecuting Christians in Syria.
He was persecuting followers of
Jesus in the Jewish diaspora,
not in Judea at all. That's what Paul
is claiming and then he goes, masses.
He goes to Jerusalem for 15 days,
but only sees these people and it's 17
years total is the first time he's seen
publicly in Jerusalem by many different
followers of Jesus that just doesn't
seem to fit here. Here he starts off
in Jerusalem, he's in Jerusalem again.
He goes from Damascus, but it
seems like it's only, you know,
a matter of weeks or months perhaps.
He's in his, in Antioch for a year.
He goes back to Jerusalem and he's an
ally for year. He goes back to Jerusalem.
Uh, he's, uh, back to Jerusalem here
in Beckley, Islam here. He's all,
he's in and out of Judy Andrews from all
the time. Which one of these is accurate
or do you believe that
now you can find really,
really brilliant fundamentalist who
believe that the Bible has to be
historically and scientifically
true and every one of its details.
And you know what? They can kind of
figure out how to harmonize all this,
but it takes a lot of very brilliant work.
It's much more likely,
isn't it?
That one of these accounts is
more accurate than the other.
Which one do you believe?
That's a real question.
Which one do you believe somebody
could make me an argument? Decide,
come on, break out of that, you know,
undergraduate shyness and
just make an argument. Yes.
You believe x, y did you
believe x? Say it loud.
[inaudible]
that sounds like a historical account.
It doesn't.
It doesn't seem like it has a
big ax to grind in Galatians.
Paul is obviously has an extra grind.
He's, he's gone all over himself saying,
I'm not lying. I'm not
lying. I'm not lying.
This fellow says maybe Paul's protesting
too much in Galatians and acts sounds a
bit more like an impartial account.
The rest of you by that everybody nods
their head. That sounds good to everybody.
Yes sir.
Yeah.
Galatians is a firsthand account.
I mean,
acts was written by someone we don't
know even know who it, who wrote it,
but it obviously wasn't written
by someone who saw this stuff.
He says he used other sources and so when
we get to the gospel of Luke and acts,
which were both written by the same
person will see that this authored admits.
They use other sources. So he was not
an eye witness of any of this stuff.
At least the stuff that he tells
him about. Uh, here in this part,
there's some debate about whether he
maybe was an eye witness for some of the
travels of Paul later and they'll and x.
But at this point he doesn't
even claim to have been there.
So wooden is a historian.
Wouldn't you take an
account by an eye witness?
The person who actually experienced
this over an account written later.
So this gentleman over here says,
no,
Paul's account is better historical
source because he was there.
Anybody else make an argument?
Well,
what about the idea that the writer
of acts is just telling a story?
Paul clearly has an an ax to grind,
not to make a pun.
Yes,
that's right. So the writer of acts
could be having an ax to grind,
which is to make the church sound more
harmonious and United and all that sort
of thing.
It may also be that the writer of
acts wants to emphasize the center of
Jerusalem and Judea and the leaders
there as the central authority.
For the early Christian
movement and so he's,
he's exaggerating Paul's presence in
Jerusalem and exaggerating the role of
these leaders in Jerusalem. So yeah,
it's a good point. The writer of acts,
we should all, we should all know that
every, uh, written account of anything,
no matter how historically good
at is still has a point of view.
Still has an agenda.
Yes.
No acts was written after the life of
Paul so Paul doesn't have access to the
book of acts as one of his sources.
Now the other question is,
did the writer of acts have access
to Paul's letters and we don't know.
Okay.
The basic time for me to wrap up here,
the basic question here is whether you
decide to trust more acts or Paul on this
issue is a historical question.
But the basic point also
is to get you by very,
very close reading of this text to see
that it's much better historical practice
as a historian to not text,
not take any of these texts as simple,
straightforward history.
What I will argue eventually is that
Paul is probably telling what is more
accurately the case. Yes, he
has a reason to stress it,
but he says it so forceful
and he writes it in a letter.
And if he had actually been in
Jerusalem as much as access,
couldn't the people who received his
letter have checked this out? Yeah,
they could. They could
basically say later, no Paul,
in spite of saying that you do
not lie, you're a liar. We've,
we know we've checked it out.
So Paul's letter I would say is much
more likely to ha to contain better
historical evidence,
but the,
but we can argue about that
till till the cows come home.
The main point is that you still have
to sift to these documents with a lot of
careful sifting to get any reliable
historical data out of them.
For example, later when we get to
Galatians some of these things,
we'll talk a bit about what really
happened in Antioch that caused the Split
Between Barnabas and Paul in
acts. It's all like, oh no,
they just had a personnel decision,
uh,
disagreement that they
parted perfectly in, in,
in agreement about the Basic Gospel.
According to Galatians,
no Barnabas and Paul disagreed strongly
over whether Jews could continue and
table fellowship with
uncircumcised gentiles and
Barnabas went along with Peter
and some disciples from James
in Jerusalem and saying, no,
even Jewish followers of Jesus shouldn't
share meals with uncircumcised gentiles.
Paul believes that Barnabas got that
wrong, so according to Paul's letters,
Paul split with Barnabas on a serious
disagreement over doctrine and practice in
the early church and again acts kind
of slides that over cause acts tries to
make the church look completely
harmonious. This is historical criticism.
Reading these texts,
just like you would read any other
ancient texts with just the same amount of
scrutiny and suspicion
that you would any text.
That's what we're going
to do in this semester.
It's different from reading
the text of scripture.
This is not to say that I believe reading
the Texas scripture is bad or wrong.
I believe it's just with a
different way of reading.
I think you can come up with good,
true Christian theological readings of
the New Testament and you can come up
with very decent historical
readings in the New Testament.
They just always won't be
the same kind of reading.
But what this class is going to do for
the most part is talking about that
historical reading. And when we
get to Paul and we get to acts,
we're going to pick these texts all apart.
We're going to ask questions like,
is any of this historical?
If so, what and why?
So start thinking that way and
then I'll see you on Wednesday.